a los combatientes extranjeros hacia la frontera.
Estas eran redes de mercenarios, no de ideólogos,
que estaban en el negocio de la coordinación por las ganancias.
Por ejemplo, a los combatientes sauditas les cobraban
considerablemente más que a los libios; dinero que de otra manera
habría sido para Al Qaeda.
Tal vez el adversario interrumpiría su propia red
si supiera que estaban engañando a aspirantes a yihadistas.
En enero de 2010, un terremoto devastador de 7,0 grados sacudió Haití.
El tercer terremoto más letal de la historia, dejó un millón de personas,
el 10 % de la población, sin hogar.
Un aspecto en apariencia pequeño de la ayuda humanitaria global
se volvió cada vez más importante cuando comenzó
la entrega de agua y alimentos.
Enero y febrero son los meses secos en Haití,
pero en muchos campamentos se habían formado aguas estancadas.
La única institución con un conocimiento detallado
de las llanuras aluviales de Haití se había derrumbado
durante el terremoto, con sus líderes dentro.
Así que la pregunta era: qué campamentos estaban en riesgo,
cuánta gente había en esos campamentos, cuáles eran los
plazos de las inundaciones y dados los muy escasos recursos
e infraestructura, cómo priorizar el traslado.
Los datos eran increíblemente dispares. El ejército de los EE.UU. tenía
información detallada de solo una pequeña porción del país.
Había datos en línea de una conferencia de riesgo ambiental
de 2006, otros datos geoespaciales, nada de ello integrado.
La meta humana era identificar los campamentos a trasladar
en función de las necesidades prioritarias.
La computadora debía integrar una gran cantidad de información geoespacial,
datos de los medios sociales e información sobre la organización
de ayuda humanitaria para responder a esta pregunta.
Mediante la implementación de un proceso superior, lo que habría sido
una tarea para 40 personas durante 3 meses, se volvió
un trabajo simple para 3 personas en 40 horas,
todas victorias de la simbiosis humano-computadora.
Han pasado más de 50 años de la visión de Licklider
para el futuro, y los datos sugieren que deberíamos sentirnos
muy emocionados de poder atacar los problemas más difíciles del siglo,
hombre y máquina cooperando juntos.
Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)